hello welcome to this 2510 game I'm kind
of surprised because I requested both
five-minute and this one this kind of
forward and I'm expected to get a five
minute game okay so um Kings in yellow
green proud so I Kings in yet it is yeah
the age 39 very popular nowadays it's
really competing with mainline status
with boo should be too in terms of
popularity on the top level yeah black
now and mostly can choose between the c5
based set up on e5 by set up d 5 based
ones are far more popular and now again
like has a choice night a-six a-five or
night h5 so it's going a 5 um ok ok I'm
going G form I'm not completely sure
about the move orders here if Bishop e3
Bishop g5 is some is better here first
on orgy form I will see G for at least
completely and make sure that night h5
is not going to happen preparing a quick
f5 maybe yeah I can even delay this
Bishop development sometime
quite often the bishop fields best only
three where it is securely anchored by
they have to pawn especially important
in case of a later f5 wow that's a very
radical decision going age 5 mm
interesting I have a couple of options
now I can try to let him take on g4 I
can play g5 or i can play Knight h2 and
night age to em instantly looks like the
right eye rightmove actually keeping the
pollen g-form and trying to provoke him
into into capturing m9 h2h takes g4 HTG
for Bishop Knight h7s is something
something that he could try going for 92
g5
yeah that's maybe an idea
hmm there are also ideas to try to give
this pawn that Bishop g5 for example age
takes to form Bishop g5 H takes d4
Knight h2 for example
on Knight d2 even 92 gtex age 3 Queen f3
for example that's very dangerous from
like night bd7 push up x3 that that
looks now that doesn't look good Bishop
g5 takes on g4 92 was this really a good
idea I mighty much just move the Queen
oh thats that certainly possible Bishop
g5 TX 92 I wonder the hammock 92 should
be right also accelerating the
development Bishop 35 takes 90 to
Queenie ate something like that maybe I
don't want to take on f6 of course not
in not totally convinced another good
option is g5 after which f5 looks very
difficult to play this is a relatively
simple solution to this it doesn't feel
like yeah trying to exploit legs play
here to the fullest down this is more
move like Bishop g5 if he takes Knight
h2 he might take h3 there this is
getting far more interesting in this in
this case mmhmm yeah g5 is much much
easier to play
Bishop g5 takes on g4 92 Queenie a this
is the line that irritates me I don't
want to take on f6 and taking on g4 is
also wrong I don't really have any good
tempo move them it feels like some
compensation but I'm not really sure if
it is a is an attic adequate one and it
is very very annoying if it wouldn't
work out and we'll have to move like g
5y just has a very nice position without
any problems hmm difficult Michael
Bishop g5 takes and just recaptures
let's say takes takes Bishop g4 Bishop
aged three years or something and i can
probably take like twenty seven so not
really okay i'm going to g5 long think
that but it is very it was a very
important important moment here because
their games the game is entirely
different of a play Bishop g5 ok so here
an interesting moment I can go look to
you one is it possible the possible move
or just Bishop e3 first I think I'm
starting with this not quite sure if I
need the rock g1 I don't leave I needed
right here in this position
interesting question is if I can try
something really brutal like that say
Brooke g1 Bishop b2 night h4 take on h5
this kind of attacking a scheme can be
can be quite dangerous if it really gets
to be played like I just said if he's
not stopping it beforehand which is very
likely possible so he wants to go to see
five years hmm
now I think I go Gucci one that really
makes f5 more difficult to play and it
prepares a possible night eh form this
idea that i just mentioned
they probably just school 95 I don't
really think that night h4b should be
two and sacrificing is going to work
just like that
uh3 might hang with this kind of idea
even though I mean it's not like he has
got huge counterplay at the moment to be
honest I don't see any counter play
yeah I wonder some people I really
completely fearless and play exactly
that yeah how to believe that this is
any good but ok maybe he has to do it in
order to get get something going here at
least not being totally passive okay so
it is not a completely clear decision
here there are a couple of interesting
options actually even yeah unites each
for it's not entirely stupid okay normal
as G takes f 6m opening up the g file i
mean i have just played rock g1 so you
basically sets routes you one is kind of
useless and okay so takes Queen texts
only move my knight on f3 is hanging
just drop it to d2 I don't know you
might even have Lucia babe six ok Queen
h5 so that's not going to work hmm i
don't think i would want to allow him to
take you so i probably have to check
that anyway night each force a little
bit interesting ok i'm going to take so
you must take with the Queen I guess and
then what exactly
yeah h2 and h3 is hanging the ship e 2
drops the pawn
hmm yeah do I really have to go 92 here
now gt5 Knight takes rook takes bishop
age 6 it's going to work so i probably
have to go back visual page six I have
Queen h5 so this is not going to be a
problem yeah five was probably okay I
mean it looks a bit looks a bit risky to
open up the g file but I don't really
have much at the moment down
enter I really have to worry a bit about
the age horn so developing just with
Bishop b2 we will probably just take
that pawn and it's really not not that
great no good development move so I
think here to get long castles in
and then check what I can do there on
the G file really not that clear how to
even get double them
yeah I thought about giving him the H
poem but if I let him take this point at
some point he also has Bishop g4 them
blocks the g foul hmm that's not that
great
hmm quite interesting so I must have
done something wrong because h5
definitely is a bad move I mean no
question but I didn't punish it maybe it
was really done something with Bishop g5
that was better I don't know all night
h2o came the position that we have no
it's not clear at all I mean I'm still
rather white but it's not not terrible
anything I'm black c5 wow he's closing
down the queenside why okay so I'm happy
about that so there's no see 6b five
business whatever with my king being on
that side of the board ok so I don't
need to prevent b5 him replace that I'm
just going to take it and again be okay
about it so am i playing Bishop g2 now
here all
how do i get doubled on the G file I
really like would like to get that in
I wonder about f3m this is a move f3 go
into H to Bishop each one then double
maybe this is an idea okay come on let's
do that it also make sure that be five
is protected by a bishop
difficult very difficult position to be
gone Kings Indian how to understand
it would be great to get the light
squared Bishop Bishop traded maybe age
form okay some splaining on b5 later
okay okay this was my idea anyway so
let's play the move and maybe I could
have gone Queen g2 hard to say cover g6
by the way hmm could have done that
maybe hi okay I mean okay he has king of
7 or this should be a door something
like that but I should have at least um
checked the move move it is worth
considering or not
too I don't really believe b5 is going
to happen now maybe is flicking in a 3
rook a to be eight maybe four be five
but I'm not sure about it I mean be five
also trade some pieces that I'm not
particularly proud of like the bishop on
f1
King h8 is also a useful move but hard
to tell I mean I could be okay this one
this is one of the Muslim at least head
on the radar as a possibility so what
about Queen g3 and then maybe like h4
and okay I mean yes to play something
awkward against this here anyway there
should be a Don or king of seven and I
want to go h4 and Bishop h3 unit that
makes quite some sense I think
yep should be a age that also will make
it tougher to play b5 always has to keep
an eye on this so it's age for Bishop e3
is still on yeah I think it did make
some sense to play at Roy at least
when a very very very very good day I
met Kenan bishop is reroute d f 1 and f
4 but has to be very carefully
considered as it opens up the g7 and it
should drop the g7 bishop okay yep it's
covering g6 very reliably at the moments
of difficult to break through
I wont to have a three is useful keeping
the pollen a form currently cannot
really do it much let's do this I think
it's a good supporting move b5 I can
just take and then take g six at the end
so that's not working as long as he has
the bishop only eight the pawn on d6 is
pretty safe I'm not able to check it
with the minor piece and in any way
maybe Bishop d3 to see 2mm taking the a4
porn then also might be an option
should be 3 root df1 FYI I don't know I
I like the idea if I'm really getting 20
get to open the position like that i
mean my pieces are pretty well um yeah
they are kind of concentrated down on
the on the kingside so maybe Bishop b3
rook f 1 f 4 is somewhat serious yeah
it's not at all easy for him to play
this position now if you notice the
small time change they have 10 to 15
seconds took a sip of water and I
figured I can't pause the video in a
thinner in a rapid game so that you
don't get irritated by the noise yeah
what is he supposed to do not quite
clear at least I see some ways for me to
improve Bishop d3 I think M is a good
square yeah very long term it might look
at the g6 porn like after f4 takes
Bishop takes then e 5 he's not really
it's nights are not really well
positioned for an f4 break yeah I kind
of talked myself into doing that even
though opening up the long diagonal is
definitely something as I said the very
responsible decision i will definitely
only play that with due preparation by
Bishop d3 Andrew gave one
now taking some time rook g8 yes this
was something that I felt is a
possibility to somehow rearrange stuff
okay let's not spend too much time there
and or I mean okay the ship age 3 is
also not completely off yeah okay let's
do this if you place Bishop f8 which
could be the idea here then f4 would
definitely be strong hitting him in the
center and twinkles b5 why is that
possible even don't I just take g six at
the end I don't get it okay is it a
point that important how I take don't
think so mice is possible I don't get
the move no matter just taking g six at
the end of this
it takes a very very long while together
hi reading in that pool the highest
rated guys they have 2050 the main
reason being that they played more games
in games and that you quite often get
here against 1,600 1,500 players you
gain one or two points and this makes it
a very yeah a very long task to get to
to higher higher rating them so you
didn't expect me to take on b5 or what
is it that you that you are saying ok so
here I have to go I for there's really
no question about that come on if he
removes the bishop from the long
diagonal this is the signal to open fire
takes Bishop takes I'm putting pressure
on d6 and have a 5 up my sleeve you know
it takes takes on f4 Bishop takes
everything gets taken on b5 then i have
e 5 at the end so while this is very
sharp i don't really believe that this
can be good with a black with all those
weird pieces on f8 nh7 and so on
hmm maybe he's going back to g7
nope it's not really doing that much can
even just take twice on g fire on e5
just take material isn't so bad ok so i
decided to capture mmm just briefly its
Queen f1 not such a totally wrong idea
to trade queens here now but I still
don't I don't believe it if he takes on
b5 now I guess you will do that with the
night and I can go if I've then
immediately and he cannot take because
of the Queen loss on the long diagonal
hmm
you cannot move the f8 bishop really you
know it only has to take them so now if
five looks like the most obvious move
after which he has to move the Queen and
I can if this is not right something is
really really wrong here in this game so
let's play it I think he has to go back
to e7 or 48 one of the two
how to play this then one idea could be
to play Bishop b5 but shouldn't be 5 and
night to you for increasing the pressure
on d6 here's the light squared Bishop
blacks LightSquared bishop doesn't feel
very very good I'm doing this come on
take here can even consider to go e cigs
but now it's not necessary really at the
moment he will take with the bishop and
now nigeria forum let's just briefly
reconsider but I think it looks good
puts enormous pressure on d6 and the
light squared Bishop that he has doing
that much
dear what is blacks best try for some
kind of swindling Queen B 6 don't go
going them for something on be too maybe
okay what am i threatening first and
foremost actually e6 were taking on d6
Italy as long as I'm not moving that
econ his bishop is not doing anything
there unknown on evade it would be nice
to get my bishop on the long diagonal of
course but probably it's really just a
six and grabbing d6 it's really not
apparent what he's doing against it just
Queen B 6 may be looking at this porn on
beach with meat so that would probably
prompt me to play something like rudy
tool or root G to not quite sure Rosie
too many
hmm well so he is covering g6
okay like it either e six if i take g6
one point is that Bishop b5 is trading
trading stuff rather quickly u6 however
is some completely killing his bishop
p.m. and i might get these six okay I'm
going in six now Queen B 6 as mentioned
i have rook g2 or rooty to both of them
but he really has to worry about the d6
porn then when creed be 60 can still do
because of the main threat but next move
he has to worry about me capturing that
pawn on d6 d6 faults then those two
points will be decisive in the center
Jack swindled swindled swindler that
that's what he needs to try to find some
kind of swindling chances
Queen B 6 rubgy to work the ATM that
saves the D porn for the moment but well
it's not exactly very inspiring so it
tries this
so he's got it covered for the moment
hmm
it looks better on the F file I mean
he's not really having it doesn't have
many moves here Bishop on e eight is
basically stalemated can move the f8
Bishop to e7 but I go just go 95
yeah i was thinking just 95 just
wondering if Bishop b5 is something here
it's close close to working now okay
this is a simple move and probably just
a good one if you just trade things now
on g5 the resulting position will still
be very nice okay pawn takes on Bishop
Teague's Bishop Texas it's good
yeah very good control over this
position nothing should happen here
it takes g5 there's a number of good end
games Queen g5s is just a simple move
Queen takes rook takes kill it looks
pretty dominating Bishop g5 I mean I can
also take with the pawn and continue
with Queens on the board 94 and yeah 94
and Quincy three then it's very strong
so Bishop g5 H tapes g5 I'll to keep the
queen's own good
and then threatening we should be 794
keeping d6 attacked and threatening
Quincy three large possible to stand I
don't think that this what he did that
was c5 and so on the disposal such a
great idea position filled cannibal felt
kind of okay even though I still don't
think age five is any good
yeah pretty much owner out of moves him
b6 rook covers d6 can go nowhere really
don't forget that this is increment 10
seconds so it's not going to be in a
flag win here by him ticking down to
nothing and be having like 15 minutes he
always has the 10 seconds but now it's
really more about the quality of the
position so I'm just taking and gone
it4s some plant
yeah no 94 was the idea say anything
anything wrong with it I don't get I
don't think so don't be 3 i'm taking d6
with the Queen no and the thread is
Quincy three now or taking on d6 for
that matter
just if he goes 27 I really shouldn't
ignore the the idea of mate humbie to
this is something to look to check so
okay I'm taking here now and they have
Queenie 5 as a thread so maybe Quinn g7
here
okay so here I've got the check check
and Knight f6 check next
check black resigns okay so let's have a
look at this game yeah this is aged five
move was very controversial I spent four
minutes now yeah a couple of interesting
options ready I was interested in this
move mostly but after this this it's
clear that he cannot really take after
Queen f3 I think the position gets very
very tricky I get this back and wow that
that doesn't look good but I thought
Queenie 8 and I didn't really see a
great move here something like this but
is this really is this really a complete
compensation I wasn't sure something
like this maybe Amanda back and go back
at equals f 5 I don't know this is then
this is something that I saw and it
wasn't really convincing me so much ok
finally g5 all that looks normal really
and now I went rogue cheap one and let
f5 yeah i mean the computer wants to do
this that's nothing I really consider
that much yeah i saw this but i wasn't
wasn't convinced back here now engine
likes white him but not much just have a
pond maybe h5 is not that bad but i I
don't I don't know ok so this I mean
here it should be something better for
white still the structure is static I've
got more space and this this doesn't
feel entirely good but it wasn't a clear
clear situation at all
but this this was really surprising me
that he just voluntarily closes down the
queenside and makes this this night look
a little bit wrong I mean it was clear
that he was going for 97 95 but it
doesn't seem right I felt you should
just go night see five or six something
like that this for example castles tix I
hear 95 is good okay hmm thats if c5 is
wrong though and i think he has to be
more flexible them yeah now this f3 move
that was probably a good solution also
given by the engine f3 f4 and now i went
here yeah Queen g2 was interesting I
really didn't see I saw that too late a
smooth we should be eight looks looks
good now this is very comparable to the
game where he went when to enter there
anyway and now I went here and now back
at age four yeah i mean this must be
good now if he goes be five hits he
loses this and he tried to recruit now
with this create okay then the computer
already wants to play a form yeah maybe
but i wanted to have all my all my
pieces well positioned
yeah this is falling apart an engine is
on + + 3 almost and now it gives the
immediately five not even trading but i
think i have i went with this but now
okay now i'm playing exactly the
computer line that's good takes takes
94s yeah it's logical but it still feels
good that the engine gives the same same
moves now it wants to take on d6 with
the night yeah not bad I felt this is
this is fairly safe not doing anything
anything fancy check here yeah so this
is check check yeah it was ok and there
wasn't really any improvement that the
engine gave him so probably key moments
I mean I still don't believe in h5 but
it wasn't as bad as I thought I guess
and he and them in this position he
probably should avoid this c5 move and
play somethin play somethin normal a4 or
c6 on 95 trying to get prepare this
somewhat better c5 looks like a wrong
I'm closing off the position ok well
thanks for watching